a big new study out this morning looks
at how the me to movement is affecting
dating culture 51 percent of American
single men say the movement made them
change how they act that's according to
the new study by the dating company
match 59 percent of all singles said the
meet to movement is important to them
and nearly half to greed it started a
much-needed conversation match surveyed
more than 5,000 single men and women
from age 18 to 99 really 99 Helen Fisher
is a biological anthropologist and the
chief scientific adviser for match and
she joins us first on CTM Helen good to
see you we should point out at the
outset that this looked at it doesn't
matter who you are attracted to in this
case people all right it's just like
just how do you feel about the meets you
movement had it affect you play we said
59% of singles find the movement to be
important but when you look at men alone
it's less than half so is that enough to
actually change how we date yeah well
fifty-one percent of men have changed
their behavior
forty percent of men have changed their
behavior at work and 33 percent of men
have changed their behavior on a date
and actually social scientists have been
tracking social change for decades and
that's a huge change I mean if you get
people to stop eating to try to ask
people to stop eating sugar or get some
more exercise or you know drink that so
it's a very few people really change
their behavior this is a massive social
change we know how their behavior is
changing yeah I say well they're being
more reserved they're being more careful
they're trying to make sure that their
jokes are appropriate that they have the
right kinds of conversations and what's
so interesting about it for me is that
actually with this me tube movement you
know 90% of men would be perfectly happy
if a woman asked them for their
telephone number 90 percent would be
perfectly happy if women made the first
sexual movement and and had a kiss I was
thinking about this last night I thought
should we reinstate Sadie Hawkins day to
try and figure out you know so it's
interesting how in business women are
really going for equality
whereas in courtship they're still
playing
much more traditional game is it the
women playing the traditional game were
is if the men being overly cautious now
I mean are they over correcting ninety
percent saying they want the woman to
make the first move
if the correction is exactly the right
word for it I mean it's a little like
the stock market there's now a
correction but what's really happening
is we're seeing growing equality between
the sexes and in fact we are shedding
actually ten thousand years of our
agrarian tradition I mean we used to
believe a woman's place was in the home
that the man was the head of the
household till death do us part and
indeed we're seeing this massive change
towards general equality between the
sexes and the last part to really change
is this but this is a huge social
movement that is moving us towards this
economic social sexual equality between
the sexes your study said that one-third
of young singles say their financial
situation has held them back pursuing
love yeah what's it you know I study
Millennials I'm really impressed by
Millennials they're very cautious and
they're very ambitious and and it sounds
like they're very practical they're very
practical I mean very different from my
generation I'm a baby boomer they're
married much later I call it slow love
they're spending a lot of time they
first they want to be just friends
then they want to move into friends with
benefits you learn a lot to do these
days right and then and then they slowly
tell friends and family and then they
slowly move in together and then they
Wed and the later you marry the more
likely you are to remain together so
it's a very interesting solid good
movement but they're being very careful
just like you said they want to make
sure they're financially stable that
their career is in order before they
actually catch feelings I love when you
say that we are built for love and yes
there are words 75% of the of those
surveyed said they believe in a lifelong
partnership yes and some you know I've
done this study with mats for nine years
and every single it's a national study
we do not pull the match members it's a
national representative sample of
Americans based on the US Census and
every year I asked that question and
some years as much as eighty nine
percent of of both men and women believe
that when you find the right one you can
do it forever and it's entirely possible
in this day and age the later you marry
the more
like who you are to remain married and
that's what the young are doing they're
being very cautious very practical as
you said and they're being optimistic
yes they are optimistic interesting
should be for God's sakes you know
interesting that most singles meet
through dating apps interesting study
Helen Fisher thank you so much for being
here
thank you